Let's bring you more now on what has been happening in Somalia.
An extreme drought which our Africa correspondent, Andrew Harding,...
…reported on two weeks ago.
He's now returned to Somalia to see its impact in another part of the country.
Now, Somalia has a long history of droughts...
…but climate change has made the intervals between them shorter...
…and the current one is the worst for 40 years.
Let's show you what it looks like on this map...
…which uses data from a USAID group that monitors famine.
The areas that you see marked in orange there are classed as being in crisis...
…and the red ones are classed as being one step worse...
…being in emergency condition.
And then there's an area which you can see marked in dark red on the map...
…and that is where a full-blown famine is projected to begin within weeks.
The definition of that is where households have no food,...
…children suffer acute malnutrition, and people die every day from starvation.
Now, Andrew's report that you're about to see comes from a place called Dolow.
And that's where people have been coming in search of life-saving help.
A warning that you are likely to find parts of it difficult to watch.
From the parched plains of southern Somalia, a weary exodus.
These families have trekked for days across a hostile wilderness in search of food.
Tens of thousands have made similar journeys in recent weeks, drawn to places like this.
The crowded outskirts of Dolow, a border town, where some help is at hand.
The local hospital, funded by Britain since the last famine here...
…back in 2011, is playing a vital role.
The baby is really very severely malnourished.
Pamela Wasonga, a nutrition expert from neighboring Kenya...
...is afraid of what lies ahead.
Somalia needs help.
Now?
Now.